federal investigators are looking at the
safety harnesses passengers were wearing
during Sunday's deadly helicopter crash
in New York City the five people killed
were part of an aerial photography tour
their pilot was the only survivor
wreckage from the crash was retrieved
yesterday
Kris Van Cleave is following the
investigation Chris good morning and
some disturbing details we're learning
absolutely Nora good morning now the
pilot told police a tether from a
passengers safety harness wrapped around
the helicopters fuel shutoff lever it
looks like this one here now it's on the
floor of the helicopter near some of the
flight controls that accidentally cut
off the fuel supply the pilot said
additionally investigators now say
they'll also look at everything from the
floatation devices to photos and videos
taken during the flight as the chopper
took off Trevor Cadogan shot this video
from the front seat the five passengers
were all wearing safety harnesses seen
here before the open door sightseeing
flight now the National Transportation
Safety Board has questions about the
functionality of those harnesses CBS
News flew with passengers on that same
helicopter with what appears to be the
same harness system back in November you
can see how the harnesses connect people
to the helicopter a carabiner hooks into
a metal ring on their backs so they can
lean out for pictures we took a flight
over Manhattan when the helicopter
crashed into the East River Sunday none
of the passengers could get out divers
had to cut through the harnesses by then
it was too late I can't even reach this
part of my back let alone find a
carabiner so that I can get myself off
of the helicopter and out Eric Adams was
on a different chopper during Sunday's
trip he took these pictures of the
Liberty helicopter charter during its
final flight Adams says the group did
receive a safety demonstration but in
light of the crash he believes essential
details were missing including the
location of a knife like this one used
to cut the harnesses tether I couldn't
tell you right now if it was on the left
side the right side high on the harness
low in the harness in the mid
and they weren't talking to us about how
to get out fast those harnesses are not
standard on that helicopter they were
added for photography flights the two
companies involved in Sunday's flights
say they are cooperating fully with the
FAA and the NTSB the NTSB does plan to
speak to the pilot about what went wrong
so tough to look at the video of those
kids before they're those young people
before they're taking off so full of
life it doesn't seem like they had a
chance
it really doesn't upside down in frigid
air water in the dark with a complicated
seatbelt harness system it's a recipe
for disaster
very disturbing thank you very much
Chris